because I do [ __ ] anything to have
what you got did you and Matt ever fight
over who was gonna play Will and who was
going to play Chucky no Matt the way
that movie started was he he was in a
um it was actually directing class but
he had taken all the acting classes to
college and I had already moved up to LA
to start acting and he was about to come
out to LA that summer and he said and I
came back into town and he said do you
want to come into my directing class I
want to do a scene I was like well what
is the scene that you want to do he's
like I have this idea about a like a guy
who's like a like a really smart guy but
he's not educated he wanted to play
basically a guy from South Boston who
was really really smart and people
underestimated hanging around here is a
[ __ ] waste of your time you don't
know that and I was like that's a really
good idea and then we sat down and you
know us and he's wrote some stuff a
scene for that and he wrote and then uh
and then we talked about we should
really write this we should really write
this and we were just young enough to be
like so incredibly stupid and naive that
we thought like why would we write you
know what I mean like that we actually
should do it and that someone might make
it